[Music]
iggy you're gonna have to be
alone guard the house because i can't
bring both of you
mines is away today
so i'm bringing my uh
oh you're gonna hate this oh my god
that's the cutest thing
so yeah we're going all the way to
odaiba in a taxi and hopefully this will
be okay
[Music]
[Music]
i don't know if i said it but i'm here
to in odayaba to pick up the tesla
i didn't pay for the delivery it was
like three grand i'm like no so i'm
supposed to go to the parking lot of
this giant shopping mall and i'm
supposed to just pick it up it feels a
bit like
a drug deal
you just pick up your car at a random
parking lot i don't know if it's correct
or not but this is technically like they
call it garbage island
because they make it out of all the
trash i will have to google it because
it's kind of sick i see a bunch of
teslas
so i think i'm in the right place i
found it
looking nice
oh we did it maya we got the car it
smells like nice new car here
this is nice that's my car now that's so
cool that's actually kind of sick i
thought someone was supposed to be here
but i guess they're not so you get to
pick your registration number the four
numbers you might have guessed which one
i picked just gotta take off the test
line plays are so nice too uh they're
walking me through some couple of things
i don't think they normally do that
uh very cool
i'm just like playing around with the
settings i guess okay first time driving
tesla
i'm going crab speed you should always
take it slow a new car you know you got
to reset your brain
this is cool well there's so many
tesla's here
that's uh a lot more responsive than i'm
used to it seems to break for me right
yeah and right now i'm not breaking
look at this potato you did so good maya
made it home that was such a good drive
she was being so calm i brought maya i
don't know if i said it but she can't
see well so if we leave it at her home
alone she just gets really lost and
stressed out and confused so if i can
bring her and yeah we definitely bring
you she likes to do this rubbing face
rubbing
it's so cute
but yeah it drove amazing it was such a
smooth and nice drive i really really
liked it
so yeah i got got a charger now
with my hidden cable
edgar i've been watching him on the
camera he's been sleeping by the
entrance
yes
don't be so sentimental i was gone for a
few hours
oh it's time to go huh
you little baby huh
got my bank account card i think at
least
global pass we're just getting more and
more settled in here this feels very
nice since mars is awake today still
with friends
i might take the dogs out
for a little tesla ride this time you
can come
i'm sorry i left you
you guys comfortable
that is so cute
all right we're going on a ride guys
[Music]
24
what do you think again it was not 24.
it's cold this is so good
yeah
oh
hell yeah it's a little scary this part
edgar you can look away
just me and the little ones
having a good day i wish my son was here
but
you guys can do i'm gonna try the um
autopilot now see how that works
whoa
this is kind of insane
oh it's limited in the speed
i'll have to compensate i guess
it's crazy to me how you can see the
traffic light should drive now yeah it
does i'm not doing anything by the way
this park is
massive
i'll have to bring marseille here
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
i don't know where i'm going this feels
like a family park
but it's really pretty
i got recognized a lot here that was so
bad saying no because everyone is here
so lovely but
yeah just sticking with it so i walked
from
here to here
oh my god
so it looks like half the park is uh
such enough for dogs
so you know i'll take it it's all right
we're just checking out
the naked statues
what is that
[Music]
that's huge oh there's wildcats
oh my god they're not your friends i'm
sorry
this is such a family park
i feel kind of silly being here
on my arm
that's cool
it's a good day out
it's literally just a chimney but they
decided to paint it which i appreciate
that's a nice
like no one likes those concrete
chimneys so
i appreciate that japan that's awesome
you stare with your car real
that's so cool
that's actually insane it has stardew
valley built in
pre-downloaded i love that
oh that's so cool
i don't really see myself buying it but
who knows that's so that's so cool
all right ready to go home
i guess i can't film while driving so
this is the footage you guys get this is
how it looks like
it's so silly
[Music]
we're driving
too pallet town again like pokemon that
has to be which one came first
the town of pokemon yeah this is odaiba
it's uh i read a little bit about it
because i was talking about it earlier
and i don't know
so it is an island made of landfill so
it's a trash island basically it was
originally like tiny islands i think for
military purposes
and then
at the end of edo period they started
to merge all the islands into one big
island which became old
and then the economical boom stopped
in the 90s
so
[Music]
it didn't really become what it was
supposed to be
but a lot of great buildings are here
the fuji tv building where she looks
insane maybe we'll see that later
and it's a great example of modern
planning architecture
residential and green wonderful
there's team lamb so cool they're
shutting down in august
rip they have a ton of cool stuff here
they have the gundam here i recommend
checking it out and we're checking out
we're going to pallet town
[Music]
i worked out earlier so as soon as we
were right i got sleepy so i took a nap
and marcus has been watching on netflix
how cool is that it's a great show by
the way anyway let's check out pokemon
town
pallet town
so you knew it two from pokemon
where which one is it is that where ash
is from
i think though yeah
we are kind of lost and confused because
there's so much reconstruction we don't
know i think it's closed to be honest
this is kind of cool
so pretty here
we don't know where to go though
they do have the gundam shop here
i don't think we can bring the dogs
but who knows
there's the fuji building
it's kind of sick
it's got like a ball in the middle they
have all these nice gardens here super
pretty you can actually i know you can
see tokyo sorry what am i saying
oh look they have a little chair there
are you living your best life figure
we kept looking for pallet town
we found it
that took oh my i just farted
what i was saying was you can see mount
fuji from here
which is kind of sick it all looks so
like
uh closed
okay
you see the ball that's so cool
over there's the gunman that's so nice
come on eggy you will like it
[Music]
we're gonna
head back but i really wanted to go to
gundam beach since we're here might as
well check it out
i've been wanting to go forever
i love that one
[Music]
oh i love the golden one
yes
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
dude that's sick
holy [ __ ]
oh the pink one
this is uh the original for the ikea
gundam that i built that's the original
colors for it i think this is a size
smaller actually looks good though it's
a wonder the better looking one
they have so much it's insane
kind of like in these two
[Music]
that's hot
golden unicorn
oh [ __ ] yeah
oh these are sick
they even got the old school
ones love it
oh hell yeah that's it whoa
yes
i was gonna get this one but they're
sold
out i'm going for this one
i think it looks cool
that was
the most stressful thing i've ever done
i'm on the wrong floor i almost walked
out because i i got
like i can't make choices anymore i
don't know what's wrong with me
and then i saw this i'm like that's sick
it's silver
that was like paradise gundam that's
where they all go but next time i go i'm
going prepared
like i'll pick beforehand
[Music]
[Music]
we're back in odaiba
and we just thought it might be better
at night it could be nicer
we're doing a date night it's not much
uh it's kind of hot
i guess that's our thing we're doing
view sites when it's bad weather here i
mean that means no one else is going to
do it so it kind of works out going for
some italian food some good times oh we
should check out the arcade a little bit
they had one there
i think this is where we wanted to go
the other time
that's amazing so we were looking for
this last time oh they had peace first
they always have the cutest on ones
[Music]
christmas comes early in japan
because why not
i think we're going to that restaurant
over there
because it's got the view or the rainbow
bridge
it feels so strange being in tokyo and
there's so few people
i don't know if we're going like on
weekdays but
it's empty
this view though
they got a fake beach over there too
maybe that was the original no i don't
know i'm just making stuff up for the
end whoa
whoa
does it pass the italy test this is so
pretty
just a bit like you go to disneyland
[Music]
i had an amazing meal
with amazing view
of a italian girl italian place very
nice
and now we're going to do their account
love that sensory overload this is like
i think it's only me and marseille in
here
[Music]
it's awful you can get a
cooked pikachu here
look what i want guys
pretty cool
you like the crayfish i want it for you
here you go
[Music]
oh my god i have to shoot it all the way
why
do you see this
[Music]
that's it
double
it's unheard of
[Music]
[Music]
do you want to train
you're selling cray-fray
fresh oh
they can be friends
[Music]
you found other fish
but you have the greatest fish here look
is that statue of liberty
why is it here
yeah fear crayfish
damn the nighttime we went too early i
think
drone school
that's so awesome
you can go to drum school so everything
is closed that's kind of our theme it's
raining a little bit
i feel the love
you want the camera i thought you
weren't
you're so mean
i'm not gonna do that that's gross
fine
[Music]
we went to a donkey shot
go on outside
touch grass they need to
be really into camping here japanese
creatine
gotta have it so these shops are like a
splurge of things
that's kind of fun actually i'm down to
get that
what the [ __ ] is it
i like it
i want to try this
how does this work that could be us
i think this is a slide for your food
this shop is actually insane they have
so much that
like anything you can think of they have
in here they have groceries as well
what the [ __ ] oh my god this shop never
ends i'm scared for my life
[Music]
[Music]
i'm heading to the edge of it
all right so taking out the toyota today
my lovely lovely wonderful
sona oh yeah merch is here too and you
know what
i parked it
just fine
it only took me three tries
you thought it was funny we got rain
covered
how are we doing in there
that's so cute
uh we're going to a grocery store an
italian grocery store our lovely
neighbor came and gave us this amazing
gift i'll show it actually so
we're gonna give a thoughtful gift back
[Music]
how are we doing in prison
nice i swear if it could be in italy
right now
some parts look so similar to where
martial lives it's weird
[Music]
[Music]
people look in expecting to see a baby
and they see this
sweden
they have
princess torta
tosuke
i think we'll get marzia's favorite
princess cake
will get one of those
that's pretty
i see no difference
[Music]
you're so cute maya
you ready for a bike ride
how are we doing here
i can like say
i bet i look as silly as i feel
but i think edgar thinks he looks really
cool
so i got this random drink
that was cringing because it's so
sour in my opinion it's sour but myself
tries it i was like wouldn't it be funny
if i thought this was sweet yeah and
then i drank it and it was sweet it's
not sweet it's super sweet okay you're
gonna have to turn
it's sour
[Music]
so the ride was nice but edgar kept
squashing my balls
so i made it very difficult what do you
have to say for yourself again
finally
revenge
[Music]
i'm the kind of guy that films our food
now this is what we're eating
it looks amazing
a little mushy probably
is it holding together
we got some cups
because we're missing a lot of home
stuff
such a nice temperature
it's really nice to be biking
what happened
here huh you fell asleep
oh baby
they made a statue of jaeger
there it is
oh yeah mine's that's homemade so these
are uh the river spirits
thank you river spirit you already had
one
you know as much as i say i don't like
cables
here they have a certain aesthetic i
will admit
[Music]
you